Fox NFL Sunday is Terry Bradshaw is
going to be featured with a football
life premieres Friday September 13th at
10:00 Eastern and Terry joins us now
Terry good morning thanks for joining us
how's the arm my arm yeah I'm looking at
it how far could you throw it right now
right now one time maybe maybe 30 yards
remember I had to retire because I
snapped the autumn of when he called
that ligament something the ligament
that Tommy John surgery whether that
ligament is I snapped it never had it
fixed I would have been before Tommy
John surgery so I opted out of Tommy
John surgery tried to rebuild the muscle
around it but doctor never said oh he
build the muscle around it he'll be
strong but you'll have a lot of pain
because of football
so I not having the Tommy John surgery
for sure your favorite memory though the
one that you'll tell your grandkids is
what oh man I I guess I I would suppose
it would be one memory would be this for
Super Bowl Super Bowl nine I've always
said that's the most important Super
Bowl in my in my life and I think for
the Steelers in the city so it looks
Super Bowl 9 I would guess
I always look back dan and I don't have
a lot of really good wish I had I wish I
had played better than I have more but
there was something about you in big
games though Terry what what was it
about a big game that brought out your
best I had been like that my entire life
and everything that I had done
whenever corners I always come out
you know swinging and playing well in
cards the same way and dom 9 and 18
everybody knows i played my best at 9
and 18 my wife will tell him hey he wins
me and they can but it's just I don't
know how you does it I don't know what
it is maybe just the focus issue maybe I
get a little more juiced up more excited
about it it's just fun to be in those
situations it's scary I look I'm not
comfortable ah but the results are even
when you think about the results of
playing well in big games man that is a
that's a rush that's a that's a great
rush and but I think primarily it was my
focus I really dialed it up where
nothing would would bother me at the
interceptions
I played poorly in the first half
against Rams in Super Bowl 14 only to
come back and and hit three bombs so I
it's just it's an it's my nature I guess
it's not anything different it's just
for some reason I always play well not
always but most of the time played well
in big gangs and some athletes are
afraid of losing or the fear of losing
and that's that's a murder right sure
absolutely you don't think I wasn't
afraid of losing uh I was petrified of
losing especially a Super Bowl my
greatest fear Dan my greatest fear
and don't think I didn't think about
this with a minute I walked out on the
field and maybe even during the game
when things weren't quite going as well
a reclose has got a little looser
got a I don't want to lose this game I
did not want that mark on my career of
being quarterback that had lost Super
Bowl I I just could not tolerate that
mentally emotionally maybe that was my
driving force but to lose a Super Bowl
was unfathomable to me
I don't know personally hi I could have
endless
I know it would have had a horrible
impact on me because I just could not
bear the thought of losing that game do
you care where you're ranked with
quarterbacks no I mean why should I care
I had my moment and I did the best I
could I wish I'd have done better I wish
I'd have been a better completion god I
wish my interceptions TVs better I'm to
12 touchdowns to 10 interception doesn't
you know why should I be mentioned with
the grace of the Great's especially when
you start adding up the numbers that
we're seeing in the last 15 years or
national bowling it's kind of
embarrassing really I've even made a
comment that when when Brady and Ben and
all and rivers and I'll see and Greece
for sure and all these guys come out I
don't know if they got enough room in
the Hall of Fame for all of us that
barely completed 50% and barely threw
for 25 thousand yards they put us in
another room somewhere honestly it never
has bothered me because on the Fox show
they'll obviously they pick on me
constantly and when I have enough I'll
say oh we can let's get the ring get the
rings out let's throw them on the table
and mine will still be rolling when your
says stop and so that's that is my 1 1
comeback how I came in one morning he
goes you know how your friends are yeah
and I can't believe this guy said this
and I told him he is not dumb he is this
and I'm like okay but read that you
don't really have to defend me on that
so it's how it comes in one day Allie
how he's upset about a bug he says did
you breathe that article no what article
of the top 50 quarterbacks in the NFL I
went no I don't I don't read those kind
of article don't anywhere you get that
stuff you guys you weren't even in the
top 25
how was ready to hit somebody
Oh Holly it's okay I don't care it does
I did my job I did the best I could I
wish that we had one more wish
personally my stats were impressive but
they weren't it was kind of the nature
of me and the nature of the way the game
was played back in the seventies and and
I don't regret it and I'm not ashamed of
it not embarrassed I'd go on and I've
had a good life listen being his
statistically dull as I was you know i
I've had a good life I've accomplished a
lot of things I thought a football that
I'm extremely proud of but everything I
have today everything every everything
man is because the football it's because
of what the Steelers have done for me it
meant meant meant to me and what we
accomplished and so I'm proud of that it
couldn't be better
I wish that time been but now I live
with it I don't regret it and I don't
lose any sleep over it he's Terry
Bradshaw on the 9th season of NFL
Network's a football life features Terry
tonight at 10:00 Eastern you talk about
playing for Chuck Noll wasn't fun was
was riot was football supposed to be fun
[Applause]
yeah I thought I thought so I play
better when I'm having fun and I'm
relaxed and uh and the professional
football was not fun it was a business
it was brutal it was cruel hateful
people I thought that how could how
cruel people can be and and me being a
guy that loves people and I'm a comic
pleaser my wife will tell you I'm all
about making people happy I'm in my
expense that's why I do chef deprecating
that's why I laugh at all those negative
it's I want to be I want to go to bed
that night feeling good about myself the
NFL was the minute you want a Super Bowl
Dan if God's blessed and you're able to
do that you know what you're doing the
next day don't you
got to do it again next year you can't
get away from it it's and I understand
when luck retirement not having played
in Super Bowls but he got beat up and
beat up and beat up and emotionally he
just got spent and hopefully he'll
recharges batter batteries and get
healthy and maybe change his my I doubt
it but maybe and I think I I wanted to
retire after eight years I told my dad I
just had enough
I just god dad I'm just you know just
had enough and I didn't have any money
I have piece of land and a few cows and
I was making about the kind my goal my
goal was 50,000 so what do you think I
was making
I [ __ ] make $60,000 a year yeah I saw
Odell Beckham's watch and it was 250,000
for a wife I'm praying someone step on
it and break it my $50,000 he's wearing
a watch
Fortuna that would pay off you know what
that would pay off what would that pay
off they would let's pay off most our
house wouldn't it we still have quite a
bit on the haha but we do we keep moving
heading over here on the hill we boot
over another hill that cost money you
know when you knew these trailer houses
you're putting you're spending some
money but that was my goal was to get to
50 grand and that's so I told Dad said
we'll do you think you know you're going
to be happy and I said yes is what are
you gonna do and I said I'm on the farm
that's what I've always wanted to do
I'll go back in my farm and and and then
of course I added it up an old federal
land bank a hundred thousand dollars for
some equipment now 30 or $40,000 on 170
head of cattle
I bought South Louisiana and I and I'm
like man so I actually played for the
wrong reason I've never said that before
that won't be in the show tonight but
there and I wish I had gotten out
earlier cuz to go back and exit your
quest and it was this fun it's it wasn't
fun for me for me if I've been cherished
and idolized you know like
although Elway and Marino maybe
different I didn't deserve to be that
wasn't wasn't gonna happen but yeah I I
should have gotten out earlier actually
nobody knows this I'll tell you because
you're my guy I had done a pilot for NBC
called the stalkers out ready we won an
Oscar for the Godfather that he produces
Johnny Carson productions hal needham
who was running sky and director and all
those great that that was our production
and Direction team in the network and
they had a con when I had a contract for
three years of the stockers with Mel
Tillis and for more money in one year
than I was going to make in four years
playing football and since I was
thinking about retired this all fell
into place nice play and that was picked
up but it wasn't and if you saw it and I
hope you never do clean it you could say
that your your choice of playing back in
the NFL Terry was a wise one because it
was so bad but that's the only reason
you came back was money yeah pretty much
I don't have any I know that you need I
love you I know I know that you you know
you'd like to laugh at yourself but you
there's sometimes some truth in every
bit of kidding where you're talking
about hey I'd like to be beloved like
like Elway or like Marino
why weren't why did you not feel like
you were beloved I it feels like you're
under estimating what you meant to well
I think I know they love me
he's a Pittsburgh loves me now I think
the a pretty powerful word anyway I
believe the identity of Pittsburgh was
not Terry Bradshaw and smart and
stalwart it was it was Franco and the
running game and it was so Steel Curtain
that was our identity and we copied that
from Miami because I recall
a conversation with Chuck Noll and he
says we're going to draft this running
back out of Penn State and we're going
to go to we're going to run what they're
doing in mind we want to control the
ball big defense and so forth and well I
don't even know why call that a so tell
me this but which was fine with me and
that's what we did and we ran the same e
office that Miami ran with kick and
danke the exact same place because Chuck
plate for Shula we ran the tossed traps
the flips the Suites the dives of 34
seeds and the all that Stoppard was the
same that they ran in Miami and and we
won four Super Bowls why I was I maybe I
was maybe people did but I was also the
focal point of you know you know if we
didn't play well obviously the
quarterback and and rightfully so so it
is and I don't think I like that
you know I don't I didn't like that and
I didn't like the fact that I felt
underappreciated which I think a lot of
athletes do you feel unappreciated and
it makes it easy if you say hey I'm not
good you know get somebody else in here
oh I'm not gonna lie to you uh leaving
was easy for me and people get mad at me
and because I don't come back but there
was nothing to go back to what was the
going back to yeah I went to work I had
make a living I had to find out where my
next paycheck was coming from this Chuck
says always said go get into your life's
work and I took that to heart you're
right just shake hands to your to your
present and and watch it walk and behind
you and becomes you know your past and
you turn around and look forward to the
present and that's what you're forced to
do when you're not making thirty million
dollars a year you you have to provide
for your family and and that's that was
I had to find out what excited me what
was I really going to do and and
and ranching and farming was what I
loved what I wasn't going to be rich but
I never had money anyway I never had
payment I mean I had Fame I never had
fortune as compared to fortune now and
most I made the 300 grand playing but
nobody really made it a lot of money
back then like it is now so I moved on
and I my defense mechanism is to never
look back if you look back you can't
move forward and I never got anything
out of looking in the past I've got a
gained experience I gained knowledge and
I applied them to the today and look to
tomorrow but I never could get anything
from the past maybe there's all too much
maybe there's too much hurt maybe too
much anger and there's certainly a great
deal of joy in the past for sure but
that's that and I can't go forward if
I'm still looking in the back in the
past and so that was that was who I was
that's who I am today
and I'm I say these things so people
that think I don't understand me
and there's a lot of people out there
damned that real out with that's smart
that's smart you got it you got to put
your foot forward and I turned around
that's why I get up side come back for a
reunion reunion reunion and geyser Sam
Davis God rest his soul just passed away
and we've lost a lot of our Steeler
players and that does you know I'm 71
now something like who you know how much
how much time I got left here so did I
answer a question is this is this felt
like a therapy session it feels like I
love you I'm happy I do feel better
good
good that's gonna cost you $300 there
for the therapy sadly good luck with the
documentary and tell the boys on the set
I said allo and congrats I will Thank
You Terry at Terry Bradshaw for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]